gentlemen making a signature blade in
your signature style man that's a piece
of cake at this point we're not doing
that instead you'll be making
one of these
that is a Mark III dive tool or dive
knife
the Mark III dive knife is a compact
multi-purpose blade that has been the
standard issue tool for U.S Special
Naval forces for over 30 years the blade
features a clip point and a long row of
serrated teeth on the back that were
ideal for sawing through thick rope
especially when underwater an
all-purpose weapon it was built to
withstand the harsh corrosive conditions
of working on the sea so what are you
going to be making these knives out of
anchor chain you'll have to combine
anchor chain with some 10 series Steel
in a sand mine technique to forge Your
Mark III's your military guys you
understand there's a standard that you
gotta hit
good luck blade Smith's your three hour
starts
now anchor chain it's not a hardenable
metal but it's a strong metal so grab
the settling torch I know it's fast I
know how to use it and I can probably
without wasting too much time chop up
enough pieces for everybody to use I'll
cut them up and be done with it and move
on
I'm comfortable with the Sami downside
is making it out of this piece of chain
what is Jared doing over there man is he
just trying to straighten out that
out there yeah and he's got that work
stick on it which I think he might have
thought would make a good leverage until
it gets really hot and which one it just
bends easier than the chain
the process I'm doing right now is I'm
trying to get the 1095 Smash down get
these two miles sealed on each side of
it and start making the shape race
profile
[Music]
use the Mark III before that's all the
experience I have with the knife like
this never made one but it's about the
attitude you have I'm here to have fun
I'm having fun Elijah over here who
basically got it mostly straight went
right to the Press went squish smart
move
so I got my three pieces of metal
they're clean smooth flat flush and then
finally it's hot enough to get my Forge
well done Lee's preparation was the
cleanest I've seen each one of those
pieces of Steel was matched up
beautifully just sent as well as on big
blue looks beautiful
the next thing I need to do is get my
tip hammered in
getting that clip point right you can
always take a rectangular bar and grind
a good point on but again to forge it in
takes a little pre-work you want
parallel sides and then a demarcation a
knee where that starts to drop off I
like to hammer and use the Anvil this is
where the form is coming from this is
what is going to determine whether you
have a butcher knife or a machete
when I'm shaping this knife out uh only
thing in my head is parameters making
sure I meet them so I'm constantly
looking at the knife on display to make
sure I got the profile correct
Jared's he's already got what looks like
a tang and the tip worked in there I cut
off the end of my Billet perfect
everything is solid
and then I go to weld on a piece of
rebar to use as a handle
and it's hot oh boy
so I got a nice little burn on my hand
oh yeah he cooked himself good yeah okay
I got a glove it's just another obstacle
in an already difficult competition yeah
got the blade within the parameters
about ready to quench
there's no Tings there's no cracks
now that I have a hardened blade I need
to put the saw back on and just clean it
up you got to be careful of the sharp
angles they think that they leave in the
spine because that can be a weak point
if not done properly
saw teeth on it
now I'm just going to try to clean it up
as best I can
there are countless ways to put these
saw teeth in I am going to do it the
fastest most efficient way I know how as
I cut in the Sawtooth blade and I pull
back I let that grinding wheel curve off
the top of the last tooth I've done then
I cut the next two you putting those
teeth on before the quench put all those
teeth become stress points during the
quench each one of those teeny little
tips is going to get really hot and so
allow the stress to happen on that solid
blade that solid Billet with as much
metal as you can there then cut those in
as opposed to allowing that stress to
happen when you've created all these
possible stress points
it's got a little bit of a kick to it
but that's something I think I all
completely grind down I start grinding
in my false Edge and then I remember oh
wait I have to put saw teeth in this
thing I've never done a sawback before
but it's actually working really really
well
I need to get this plate heat treated
so heat it up put it in the oil I file
test it I've got a hard Edge five five
four three
two one placement shut down your
machines drop your tools this first
round of competition is over good job
[Applause]
to test the strength and durability of
your blades as well as the overall
construction I'm going to be bashing
them mercilessly into this anchor chain
remember this test is all about what
that chain does to your knives and not
what your knives do to change Jared
you're up first you ready I'm ready
I'm nervous as can be right now that
chain is going to be brutal I don't know
what to expect when uh that chain gets
hit
[Music]
well Jared it's pretty evident what
happened here
the one thing that I talk about a lot
are things called stress risers and
where things rapidly change geometry it
tends to concentrate stress right there
and this broke right at your very first
Sawtooth so usually with saw teeth like
this you want to have a curved bottom
because it kind of distributes that
stress
Jared your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure on the fifth strike
against this chain and you can no longer
continue with testing however the
fight's not over for you each of you
will have to survive five strikes in
order to move forward this competition
all right Ben
Lee you've seen what I'm up to how you
feeling pretty nervous
my blades quite a bit wider you know the
steel is welded up good together but
that chain just destroyed that blade my
stomach's just doing flips
oh my God
[Music]
well Lee
your grain is beautiful it's like velvet
you know it's it's should be a very
strong Blade the spot of the the break
again it's right at the base of one of
these saw teeth
Lee your blade suffered a catastrophic
failure after only one strike on this
anchor chain everything right now
resides on the largest plane your blade
will have to survive one strike on this
anchor chain are you ready for this no
I'm confident that the steel is hard but
Jared and Lee's blades just broke leaves
after one hit
it all comes down to my blade
I can't see what an iron steel is
Elijah looking at the the knife that you
presented here there's a couple major
issues one is that this guard is all
over the place but the one big issue I
have is that
there's no acid etch on this blade yes
sir
I can't tell on this side where hardened
steel is or soft steel is I like to be
able to see where the steel is so that I
can accurately judge what you've done
gentlemen the parameters exist so that
we can measure your blades evenly and
fairly with one another Elijah you
failed to meet the parameters by failing
to acid etch and your guard is loose
so the judges have given your blade a
vote of no confidence I have to ask you
to please leave the forge I understand
my friend I'm an officer in the United
States Navy I'm about upholding the
rules and if I got to go forward it
wouldn't have been right
the first thing I'm going to do when I
get home is kiss my wife and kiss my
kids and pores a rubber stacked Mark III
dive knife
so that I can hang that sucker up on the
wall as a constant reminder of attention
to detail